[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous je dis 5 abril bienvenue
dans le 7-8 journal sur tv 78 tour
d'horizon de l'actualité locale tout de
suite les titres de cette édition
deux membres du gouvernement en visite à
saint cyr l'école jacques mézard et
julien de normandie se sont rendus hier
mercredi à la zac renard le quartier a
été prise en exemple du projet de loi
est lent sur le logement
le texte a été présenté hier en conseil
des ministres la vie à deux peut parfois
se confronter à certains problèmes le
projet aime ton couple se donne pour
objectif de résoudre ces tracas
rencontrés au quotidien
une initiative portée par une
association yvelinoise soutenu notamment
par le département les détails à suivre
et puis il a rouvert ses portes au
public après une pause hivernale le parc
france miniature à elancourt vient de
débuter sa saison 2010 8 est l'occasion
de découvrir va les plus beaux monuments
de france en format réduit et mais aussi
avec quelques nouveautés dans ce journal
également des invités nous recevrons des
membres de l'association cap évasion
elle sensibilise au handicap en
utilisant notamment les moyens du sport
et des loisirs et nous parlerons
également de l'événement
l écologie corporels dans tous ses états
une journée d'information pour mieux
connaître la nature de votre corps c'est
ce samedi à maurepas et le gouvernement
a donc présenté hier en conseil des
ministres son projet de loi sur le
logement élan pour évolution du logement
de l'aménagement et du numérique
l objectif c'est de répondre notamment à
la problématique de l'offre et à la
hausse des loyers et de membres de
l'exécutif qui porte ce projet se sont
rendus hier à saint cyr l'école le
ministre jacques mézard et le secrétaire
d'état julien de normandie ils se sont
rendus au coeur de la zac renard à terme
dans ce nouveau quartier mille cinq
cents logements seront construits
reportage de nicolas kirillovitch à
saint cyr l'école comme exemple quelques
heures seulement après la présentation
de leur projet de loi sur le logement
jacques mézard et julien de normandie
ont visité un projet de construction
emblématique en ile-de-france objectif
pédagogie et démonstrations dans ce
nouveau quartier de 25 hectares près de
4000 habitants s'installeront d'ici
quatre ans l'une opérant
lyon qui est tout à fait exemplaire en
ce qui concerne à la fois la mixité
sociale puisque on voit qu'il y à des
efforts considérables pour à la fois
faire du logement social faire de
l'accession sociale à la propriété de
l'accession à la propriété dans un
environnement réussi pour tenter de
créer un choc de l'offre dans les zones
tendues comme en ile de france le
gouvernement souhaite notamment réduire
le nombre de recours abusifs
aujourd'hui trente mille construction
seraient bloqués à cause de ces recours
en france
associé à l'école le projet de la zac h
en renard a été lancé il y a dix ans
déjà
c'est un projet qui remonte à 2008 même
s'il avait été pensé avant mais le
départ c'est 2008 et ça sera pas
terminée avant 2021 2022
donc vous voyez 15 ans 14 15 ans ray
commence à faire beaucoup
il reste autant à construire et à livrer
qu'il a déjà été livrée avec 1500
nouveaux logements au total beaucoup
d'activités économiques
la création de 400 emplois en activité
au économique les commerces et les
équipements publics
le projet de loi est lent du
gouvernement sera présenté à l'assemblée
nationale à la fin du mois de mai son
adoption devrait suivre quelques
semaines plus tard
bien avant la fin des travaux à saint
cyr l'école et à l'occasion de cette
visite à saint cyr l'école la députée la
république en marge des yvelines a dit
ray a interpellé le gouvernement lors
d'une séance de questions à l'assemblée
nationale hier mercredi la parlementaire
a interrogé et des suites données à la
polémique au lycée militaire fin mars
nos confrères de libération révélait des
faits de harcèlement moral et
d'humiliations subies par des élèves
féminines en classes préparatoires et
dont l'établissement saint cyrien un
groupe appelé les tradi faisait subir un
véritable calvaire à leurs victimes
et face à ces agissements en tolérance
zéro a répondu la ministre des armées
florence parly les personnes impliquées
dans la sphère seront exclues écoute et
florence parly j'ai donc pris des
sanctions
d'abord l'exclusion de saint cyr l'école
des élèves impliqués dans ces faits
ensuite ensuite le remplacement après
les examens et les concours qui commence
dans quelques jours des cadres qui eux
aussi sont concernés
assorti de mesures disciplinaires enfin
enfin l'interdiction dans les classes
préparatoires de ces établissements de
redoublement pour les élèves
perturbateurs
la ministre a par ailleurs annoncé la
mise en place prochaine d'un plan de
lutte contre les discriminations au sein
des lycées militaires autres lycées
toujours à saint cyr l'école jules
hardouin mansart qui a entièrement fait
peau neuve les travaux de
l'établissement qui accueille un peu
plus de 800 élèves avaient débuté en
2010 le lycée rénové était a été
inauguré officiellement ce jeudi matin
aurélie rond et marion ctaq étaient sur
place
le chantier aura duré huit ans les
quinze mille mètres carrés du lycée
jules hardouin mansart à saint cyr
l'école ont été entièrement modernisé
montant des travaux un peu plus de 50
millions d'euros un budget entièrement
supporté par la région ile de france
on n'a pas voulu faire petit bout par
petit bout mais dans une cohérence pour
avoir un lycée du 21e siècle avec vous
le savez des moyens de technologie bien
sûr différent et une manières
d'enseigner d'appréhender les lieux qui
évidemment ne pouvait pas se contenter
d'un investissement qui n'auraient pas
été justement tourné vers l'avenir un
lycée du futur avec des façades ont pas
un rétifié un matériau destiné à durer
dans le temps
le bâtiment aux normes haute qualité
environnementale laisse également
beaucoup de place à la lumière
c'est un élément moteur de la conception
de ce projet
la lumière la luminosité partout la
fluidité la souplesse en opposition avec
la barre qui était quand même très
obsolètes était très fatigué
je dis toujours c'est un bâtiment qui
était grippé cdi salle de classe ou
encore préau tout a été refait pour le
bien-être et la réussite des 8 118
élèves
malgré tout la communauté scolaire a dû
cohabiter pendant huit ans avec les
travaux ça a été parfois des joies
immenses et des souffrances importantes
et une communauté scolaire à ressouder
ce qui me rend heureux c'est que la
plupart des professeurs qui ont débuté
la reconstruction sont toujours là
aujourd'hui
désormais les élèves du lycée jules
hardouin mansart ont toutes les cartes
en main pour étudier dans des conditions
idéales
elle cet ensemble lui devrait être
inauguré fin 2010 9 morts pas à lancer
la construction de son écoquartier dans
la zone d'activités paris ouest
il abritera à terme plus de 500
appartements est la première pierre a
été posée ce matin en présence notamment
de la présidente de région valérie
pécresse 113 logements sociaux de ce
programme ont d'ailleurs bénéficié d'une
subvention de 730 1000 euros par l'île
de france
un écoquartier qui devra répondre à cela
un certain nombre de critères comme le
précise le maire de maurepas interrogé
par patrick jacques de dixmude
c'est une gestion raisonnée des places
de stationnement c'est également une
coulée verte centrale qui à terme va
pouvoir permettre aux piétons et aux
cyclistes d'accéder d'une parcelle à une
autre jusqu'au bout de cette longue
bande rd13 de 2 800 mètres de long ce
sont des matériaux biosourcés ce sont
également les nouvelles technologies
puisque les appartements sont équipés en
domotique seront tous fibre est
également donc voilà c'est un panel un
ensemble de choses
des critères très exigeants
que nous demandent évidemment cette
charte éco quartiers dans les trois
prochaines années mort pas va construire
plus de 1000 logements supplémentaires
pour se plier à la loi sru qui impose un
minimum de 25% de locatif social est
d'ici 2025
à plaisir cela fait un an que la zone
commerciale du carré d et bizouard a été
inauguré les différentes enseignes
présentes à commencer par la marnière
primeur fêtent leur anniversaire ce week
end et des promotions et des
dégustations seront proposées au public
les détails avec ce sujet de camille
lambert +2 5 heures de cuisson à la
broche pour cet agneau
installé depuis le matin les salariés de
la marnière primeur de plaisir font
goûter leurs produits aux visiteurs
moi je viens depuis la halle à la
construction sur les produits va bien
évidemment c'est très bon s'est
comment dire ces frais comme les fruits
et légumes la boulangerie
non vraiment il n'ya rien à redire et
puis on espère surtout que ça marchera
pour eux ouverte il ya un an la zone
commerciale des débits soir fête son
anniversaire
dégustations animations une promotion un
moyen de remercier leurs clientèles et
de fidéliser les nouveaux venus il ya
déjà 2 marnières donc un mot repas qui
datent de plus de vingt ans et le
deuxième qui a été créée en 2009 à la
queue-lez-yvelines est donc là c'est le
troisième magasin de la marnière qui a
ouvert ses portes en avril 2017
on a contacté donc nos partenaires et
par rapport aux produits que
que nous faisons
venir faire déguster leurs produits en
fait directement c'est le producteur qui
vont venir faire déguster aux à nos
clients j'ai connu enseigne il ya deux
ans et donc on a fait les travaux de ce
magasin l'année dernière je suis devenu
client va en voyant les produits on voit
que c'est quand même bien présente et la
belle qualité ça donne envie
la marnière qui embauchent 45 personnes
sert environ 6000 clients par semaine
de nombreuses animations sont prévues
jusqu'au 8 avril avec les autres
enseignes du quart et sensibiliser
changer les regards sur le handicap
c'est la mission que se fixe un cap
évasion pour y parvenir l'association
utilise comme vecteur de communication
le sport la culture ou encore les
loisirs on en parle avec nos deux
invités deux étudiants du vs qu en
master de management des achats tous
deux membres de cap évasion donc alice
et mme baka bonsoir main cela vous est
la responsable communication de cette
association avec nous également acquis
midi bonsoir co responsable des
partenariats pour cap évasion alors une
première question et je vais vous
laisser répondre à tour de rôle d'abord
alice pourquoi vous vous engagez dans
cette cause du handicap
tout simplement parce que ma mère
travaille avec
des personnes en situation d'handicap et
j'ai pu au cours de mes jobs étudiants
traités et enfin travailler avec les
personnes en situation d'handicap
et lorsque le choix d'un projet au cours
de l'or de notre formation je pense
qu'on n'a pas hésité à se tourner
vers un projet associatif donc la
question ne s'est même pas posée donc
j'ai souhaité travailler envers le
handicap avec le côté pourquoi cette
thématique du handicap vous touche
alors je suis particulièrement touchés
notamment parce qu'il ya des cas dans
nos familles qui sont atteints par ce
type de handicap et le handicap mental
car voilà j'ai vraiment envie également
notre association de lever les a priori
pour les gens à l'égard du handicap
mental et montrer que qu'elles ont des
capacités et on aimerait vraiment
exploiter leur potentiel
mais justement quel regard mon porte
aujourd'hui sur le handicap mental est
ce que ça c'est un regard qui encore
faussé
à votre avis tout à fait on n'a pas idée
de des capacité qu'ont les personnes en
situation d'handicap nous on sensibilise
particulièrement sur les personnes
atteintes de trisomie
mais aujourd'hui on l'est on les
accompagne à travailler à l'essai à
s'insérer dans le monde professionnel
ils sont tout à fait aptes je pense
qu'il ya eu
justement une femme en situation de une
femme atteinte de trisomie qui a acquis
enseignante
aujourd'hui il ya énormément de tabou
mais ils sont ils ont des capacités donc
personne n'a idée voire peut-être plus
que nous
alors pour sensibiliser justement cette
thématique du handicap mental pour eux
aussi changer les regards vous utilisez
notamment il ya plein de moyens mais le
sport comme comme moyen de de
communication pourquoi c'est un vecteur
important le sport un vecteur
intéressant pour parler du handicap
alors c'est une façon pour eux de se
sociabiliser et également comme je le
disais vraiment d'exploiter leur
potentiel et grâce au sport ça allait
elles prennent de l'assurance et ça
permet vraiment de montrer aux autres
que qu'elles ont des capacités
tout comme je pense que le sport c'est
le meilleur moyen de mobiliser les
personnes qu'elle soit valide ou en
situation d'handicap
on parle et votre engagement ce alors
pourquoi c'est important pour vous que
des jeunes comme vous s'investissent du
problème parle du handicap
je pense qu'on est un petit peu là la
relève
je pense et on est aussi là pour
véhiculer un message je pense que c'est
plus fédérateur en tout cas pour nous de
prendre l'initiative de rassembler les
personnes de tout âge ça peut être
renaître les jeunes ou les personnes
âgées ou les adultes et je pense qu'on
est porteur d'un message
racontez nous un peu cette année
universitaire cette année projette vous
avez pu mener pour l'association quel
type de projet justement vous avez pu
mener cette année
donc nous sommes en partenariat avec
l'association l'apei donc accompagnement
des parents des enfants des amis et
inadapté donc nous avons organisé un
spectacle à elancourt qui consistait à
mettre en scène une cérémonie des oscars
d'accord donc on a convié les les amis
la famille pour vraiment apporté du
divertissement
et puis qu'ils puissent en l'espace de
cette soirée sortir de leur quotidien et
être vu voilà être montré que s'épanouir
voilà durant cette soirée sont les
partenariats c'est votre rayon vous êtes
en partenariat des associations c'est ça
pour mener des actions c'est toujours
primordial de s'associer à une
association est tout à fait car ton que
plus on s'associe avec des associations
et plus on gagne en notoriété et plus on
peut mettre en place des actions afin de
mobiliser un maximum de personnes
l'un des prochains projets justement il
devait avoir lieu ce week-end finalement
ça a été reporté on communiquera sur tv
78 sur la date prochaine de ce projet un
challenge départemental du tir à l'arc
adapté et vous deviez parce qu'alice à
cet événement ça veut dire hr en effet
on devait tous y participer en tant que
bénévole mais après faute d'inscrits je
pense que l'événement sera reporté dans
un ou deux mois mais il sera toujours
d'actualité mais on communique dessus
actuellement sur les réseaux sociaux et
sur notre page facebook en particulier
d'autres projets peut-être que vous
allez mener d'ici la fin de l'année oui
on aimerait par participé à aux
olympiades donc vraiment pour ce sera un
moyen de rassembler les personnes en
situation de handicap et les personnes
dites valides afin de passer tous un bon
moment également si on si on peut
participer au jeu européen
qui auront lieu du 16 au 21 juillet donc
il y aura des personnes en situation de
handicap est vraiment en tant que
bénévole on aimerait vraiment participer
à cet événement on vous le souhaite en
tout cas on peut retrouver toute
l'actualité de l'association sur la page
facebook de cap évasion qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran merci à vous deux lycées
mbaka et hakim idylle d'avoir été avec
nous je rappelle respectivement
responsable de la communication pour
cette association est coresponsable à
des partenariats avec cap évasion
sensibiliser les couples aux différents
problèmes que qui peuvent être
rencontrées au quotidien l'association
versaillaise un avenir à deux a lancé
son projet nommé aime ton couple c'est
un projet à une initiative qui est
soutenu par le conseil départemental des
yvelines et à la caisse d'allocations
familiales
aime ton couple utilise notamment
l'humour pour sensibiliser un reportage
de michael et demi d'euros et nicolas
dandois qui va faire la vaisselle
étendre le linge ou passez l'aspirateur
les questions posées dans cette vidéo
dans le cadre du projet aime ton couple
dans ce cas la sensibilisation porte sur
le partage des tâches ménagères avec
comme outil des dessins humoristiques et
généralement juste illustrer une
situation qu'elle va mener crif
et la faire
plus ou moins de manière humoristique le
but c'est de faire le moins de bulles
parce que si la troupe bull ça se voit
pas dans les vidéos ou c'est pas très
clair quelque chose à l'initiative du
projet l'association yvelinoise un
avenir à deux une vingtaine de personnes
participent à sensibiliser au bien-être
de la vie en couple à travers différents
témoignages
par exemple nous avons parlé de la
disquette 3 et c'est pas grave de ces 10
pt mais tout ça va recommencer discuter
de notre sexualité en couple
la caisse d'allocations familiales
participe au financement du projet de
son côté le conseil départemental des
yvelines apporte une subvention de 45
mille euros ça se passe complètement
dans l'objectif du conseil départemental
qui est de travailler sur la prévention
la présentant le plus précoce possible
notamment sur la question de la
protection de l'enfance mais plus
largement de la relation parent enfant
est encore plus de façon précoce sur la
relation de parent apparent prévenir les
séparations et assurer le bien-être des
familles l'association un avenir à deux
espèrent une fréquentation de 500
visiteurs par jour sur le site internet
à mieux comprendre la nature de son
corps c'est le but de cette journée de
conférences et d'ateliers son nom
l'écologie corporels dans tous ses états
c'est ce samedi à la maison de voisinage
découdre et à maurepas de 9 heures à 18
heures pour en parler d'eux invité
julian king bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
ostéopathe et professeur de wattao on
aura l'occasion de parler de cette
pratique
après vous organisez donc cette journée
d'information avec pierre marie pottier
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le président
de l'association ouest 78 un mot déjà
pour commencer de présentation sur ces
sur l'association ou et 78 tu veux dire
oui ou tao et arts énergétiques des
yvelines
le but c'est de promouvoir le goût tao
bien sûr en premier lieu qui est un art
corporel dansant et qui va vous
permettre de rentrer par une petite
porte il y en a plusieurs dans le monde
de l'énergie
dans le monde de l'écologie corporelle
cette association a été créée en 2011 et
dans sept ans d'existence et nous avons
il ya trois ans imaginez avec julian une
journée thématique sur l'écologie
corporelle l'année dernière nous avons
fait une demi journée qui a été
plébiscité par tous les participants
pour qu'elle soit beaucoup plus longue
donc cette fois ci c'est la journée
complète avec des ateliers beaucoup plus
lent parce que les thèmes abordés
passionne beaucoup de monde et demande
une écoute un peu plus long voilà des
éléments de définition ci sur l'écologie
corporels pour donner toutes les clés de
téléspectateurs on connaît le thème de
l'écologie pour la sensibilisation à la
protection de l'environnement pour
l'agriculture aussi l'écologie du corps
c'est vouloir décoller ville corps en
fait on entend beaucoup paris de
l'écologie par rapport à la nature donc
à l'extérieur la nature dans
l'agriculture etc
mais on ne pense jamais de parpaings à
nous mêmes en fait notre corps fait
partie de cette nature et notre être
fait partie de cette nature et c'était
un philosophe bernard andrieu qui qui a
commencé à parler de l'écologie
corporels en premier qui a été
plébiscité et repris par les deux
fondateurs de uta où apple chez roy il
m'a nourri cela donc deux français qui
ont créé la route alors pour m'expliquer
notre notre but dans le gotha donc c'est
une connexion à soi même au travers de
toutes formes 2d coûte de notre corps
soit dans le yoga ou le
le tai-chi le tchi kong etc mais
pourquoi c'est important d'être à
l'écouté de son corps par rapport à
l'écologie
d'accord donc en fait c'est par points
cette idée d'écologie ciron n'est pas en
connexion avec soi même parce que nous
pensons c'est que c'est beaucoup plus
difficile à comprendre pourquoi c'est
important d'avoir cette écologie vers
l'extérieur donc dans la nature est
aussi
kate où toutes les actions menées dans
plein de différentes domaines de
l'écologie de la nature alors on en
parlait justement l'écologie corps paul
on la retrouve dans certaines pratiques
leroux tao
qu'est ce que le ou tao louboutin par
exemple c'est un art corporel on dit un
art corporel voisin de tai chi chi gong
yoga et ses autres disciplines dites
interne qui permet la personne de
ressentir ce qui se passe à l'intérieur
de locaux plutôt que de faire uniquement
des choses parfois j'ai des gestes
extérieur donc la première chose à faire
c'est de ce roman se mettre en connexion
et à se connecter à ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur de son corps
donc après ça il y a cinq principes dans
l'aube ou tao qui sont à l'ondulation de
la colonne vertébrale donc de ressentir
cette ondulation à les mouvements
spirale et dont on a besoin
quels qu'ils sont partout dans le corps
c'est notamment notamment parce que je
en étant ostéopathe
oui je vois ça partout il ya des
spirales partout dans le corps et donc
c'est de remettre en mouvement à nouveau
le croit dans ces spirales naturel et et
il y à l'idée aussi du sentiment du
geste dans la grande on fait un geste
qu'est ce que ça fait dans notre coq est
ce que ça fait ça anime dans notre corps
à derniers mois donc on passe au
programme puisque le temps défile à
l'isi est donc oui on a on a plusieurs
choses qui sont lit un cette idée
d'écologie corporelle
donc on a fait donc d'intervenir bien
sûr le bhutta haut mais la danse
biodynamique
il y aura plusieurs ateliers lors de
cette voie là qui a qui peuvent nous
permettre de se reconnecter à soi-même
dont plusieurs ateliers et aussi
plusieurs conférences oui d'ailleurs
pierre marie pottier plusieurs
conférences qui vont animer cette
journée une tâche et le principe de la
journée cinq conférences cinq ateliers
qui se mène en parallèle
ça commence à 9 heures le matin ça sert
mine à 18h le soir c'est des séquences
de 1h30 très bien à nous laisse quand
même une heure et demie de pause pour
pouvoir récupérer animés par des
spécialistes animé par des
psychothérapeutes animé par des
ostéopathes animés par des professeurs
d'éducation physique qui sont aussi
professeur de boot how does she quand
les autres donc une panoplie de gens qui
ont mobilisé passionné et passionnant
qui vont permettre à tout le monde de
trouver
j'irai une information nécessaire une
connexion qu'ils n'ont pas et surtout de
pouvoir ressortir avec l' envie d'aller
un peu plus loin dans cette recherche de
l'écologie corporelle parce que c'est
une recherche vis-à-vis de soi-même mais
qui passe par la connaissance des autres
en 10 secondes pour y participer
on peut en euro symbolique mais la
participation est libre
alors la participation est offerte pour
tous les auditeurs de tv 78,6 se
présente ça l'est surtout lorsqu'on
regarde les téléspectateurs
sûr si l'on vous pouvez vous inscrire et
faire un don effectivement de don
minimal est de 1 euro sur le site ou et
78 qui s'affiche avec les voilà sur
lequel vous en est où le les ateliers la
description des ateliers la description
des personnes qui interviennent pendant
cette journée là merci à vous deux
julian king car marie pottier d'avoir
été à vegas retrouvez toutes les
informations sur cette journée de
l'écologie corporelles à maurepas sur le
site internet qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran est direction et l'on court
après quelques mois de fermeture le parc
france miniature a rouvert ses portes
samedi dernier
le public venu en famille a pu découvrir
ou redécouvrir les plus beaux monuments
de france en taille réduite et en plus
des attractions et des animations une
chasse aux oeufs étaient organisées le
week-end de pâques oblige recrues tout
retour sur cet événement nicolas landry
et aurélien admirer la tour eiffel la
cité de carcassonne ou encore le château
de chambord en quelques heures seulement
c'est de nouveau possible chez france
miniature les 117 monument répartis sur
le parc situé à elancourt se sont tous
refait une beauté durant l'hiver il faut
refaire les peintures refaire toutes les
scénographies et puis on a cinq hectares
de terrain sur france miniature donc
c'est un parc paysager
donc il ya un gros travail pour la
période de l'hiver en plus des monuments
des expériences interactives et des
attractions quelques nouveautés pour
cette saison un livret jeu pour le jeune
public mais aussi la voix de stéphane
bern qui résonnera dans le parc
un choix qui s'est imposé de lui même il
cherche à travers ces émissions à
vulgariser le patrimoine français et
c'est exactement aussi la vocation de
france miniature
donc on va retrouver des commentaires
sur albi sur le beffroi l'hôtel de ville
de douai on a retrouvé sur versailles
évidemment tous les gros monumentaux
visiteurs attendent en fait sont
sonorisés maintenant avec ces qr code et
ce guide de luxe un voyage insolite aux
quatre coins de france qui séduit aussi
bien les grands que les petits voir tout
ce qui peut tout ce qu'on peut faire en
france qu'on sait pas forcément
comme ça on n'a pas forcément aidés et
là ça donne aussi des idées de voyage ou
se balader en france c'est vrai que ça
c'est sympa on peut voir shakarchi
architecture avec tous les détails comme
si c'était la vraie une réouverture qui
est tombée cette année pendant les fêtes
de pâques
à cette occasion une chasse aux oeufs
étaient organisés et rien de mieux
qu'une note chocolatées pour lancer
cette nouvelle saison
un mot de sport avant de refermer ce
journal la dernière étape du tour de
france sera résolument yvelinoise le 29
juillet prochain
d'après nos confrères du parisien le
tracé entre ouïe et les champs-elysées
devrait passer par une quinzaine de
villes du département
férole chavenay et villepreux notamment
pour une boucle de 40 kilomètres sur le
territoire
arrivé à paris après un total de 116 km
de course pour cette ultime étape c'est
la fin de ce set 8 journal merci de
l'avoir suivi excellente soirée à tous
sur tv 78
[Musique]